More than 10 million sports related injuries
occur in the world every year. To avoid this,
athletes and coaches alike are using a variety
of pre-competition techniques to decrease
injuries and increase performance. But, what
does science tell us about stretching and
"warming-up"?
Many studies have looked at how stretching
can affect athletic performance, and it turns
out...it depends on the activity! Sports such
as figure skating and snowboarding, which
require a wide range of motions to impress
the judges, certainly benefit from an athlete's
flexibility. But for power sports like speed
skating and bobsledding, too much stretching
may actually cause a temporary decrease in
muscle strength. The overstretched muscle
becomes less responsive and can stay weakened
for up to 30 minutes.
Although athletic competitions can be strenuous,
there is little evidence to suggest that stretching
before or after a competition decreases muscle
soreness. Some studies have even noted that
extreme flexibility can lead to an increase
in the range of stretching without pain. And
if you can't feel pain, the body doesn't know
when to stop pushing; as a result, injuries
can occur. Another large study of athletes
found that the least and most flexible participants
were 2.5 times more likely to incur an injury.
So when it comes to flexibility in competitive
sports, it's most beneficial to be moderately
flexible.
A well designed 'warm up' is also extremely
beneficial. The term itself comes from the
positive effects of raising the temperature
of your body before a competition. Slowly
increasing physical intensity prior to a sport
increases muscle temperature, ultimately allowing
your muscles to contract more forcefully.
More forceful contractions, equals more strength
and power. Furthermore, slowly adding movement
to your muscles opens up the blood vessels,
allowing blood to flow more easily throughout
the body, and decreases the strain on your
heart. Finally, as your blood temperature
increases, your blood cells actually hold
less oxygen. This loose oxygen is then free
to be used by your muscles, increasing overall
endurance.
Science says, it's important not to over "stretch"
it when it comes to flexibility, but physically
"warming up" your body before each specific
sport might help you burn
the competition.
Don't forget: we have a new video out every day during the Olympics.
Can't wait? Our amazing partners at the CBC already have five of the videos up now for you to binge on.
Just head to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to watch them before anyone else. Link in the description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the hashtag ScienceSays and let us know your burning Olympic questions.
And subscribe for more awesome science videos!